[Musik]
Deutschland ist nicht nur ein sehr
wohlhabendes Land sondern auch dafür
bekannt dass es wie ein Uhrwerk
funktioniert und Dinge von sehr hoher
Qualität produziert so weit zumindest
der Ruf im Ausland wenn etwas deutsch
ist muss es auch gut sein
[Musik]
tatsache ist das Deutschland in den
letzten Jahrzehnten eines der größten
Wirtschaftswunder der Geschichte erlebt
hat wir haben euch bereits hier auf
visualpolitik und auf unserem Schwester
Kanal visual economic davon berichtet
heute ist Deutschland ein Synonym für
hohe Produktivität florierende
Unternehmen und hochqualifizierte
Arbeitskräfte es hat jedoch ein Problem
ein potenziell sehr ernstes Problem von
dem wir euch noch nicht erzählt haben
seine Unfähigkeit qualifizierte
Arbeitskräfte anzuziehen und in den
Arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren die meisten
hochqualifizierten rund um den Erdball
denken zuerst an Großbritannien die
Niederlande Kanada Australien oder die
USA wenn sie durch den Umzug in ein
anderes Land ihrer Karriere einen Bost
verleihen wollen obwohl Deutschland ein
sehr reiches Land mit vielen
Arbeitsblättern und scheinbar guten
Karriere Möglichkeiten ist scheint ist
kein attraktiver Ort für
hochqualifizierte Arbeitskräfte zu sein
es steht viel schlechter da als der Rest
der Länder in seiner Vergleichsgruppe
gut Teutonia erreicht zwar nicht das
extrem Nippons aber das ist auch eine
extreme Anomalie genauso wie Japan hat
Deutschland aber auch das Problem dass
seine Bevölkerung in erwerbsfähigen
Alter schrumpft und das wird enorme
Auswirkungen auf die Leistungs- und
Funktionsfähigkeit des bisherigen
Wirtschaftsmodells haben sowie natürlich
auf den Wohlstand aller Bürger wie
dieses Phänomen in Japan bereits zu
jahrzehntelangen real lohnverlusten und
sogar Verarmung geführt hat haben wir
vor kurzem in einem anderen Video
dargestellt dass ich euch verlinken
werde es stellt sich also die Frage
warum Deutschland für Hochqualifizierte
Ausländer so unattraktiv ist was könnte
dies für das Land bedeuten dass
traditionell ja als Motor Europas gilt
und was unternimmt die Regierung um
diese Situation zu ändern in diesem
Video werden wir all diese Fragen
beantworten so vor muss ich jedoch eine
Entdeckung mit euch teilen vielleicht
interessiert es euch ja zu sehen wo ich
eigentlich meine Videos Kräfte schreibe
nun wenn es das Wetter erlaubt dass ich
mich meistens im Garten an mein A4
ePaper Tablet und haue in die Tasten
vorher muss ich mich jedoch ausgeben ich
informieren aus dem Bett aus Studien und
natürlich aus der Presse und dabei bin
ich auf eine App gestoßen die sowohl auf
meinem Handy als auch Tablet und PC
läuft und mein lese Erlebnis geradezu
revolutioniert hat Red redley ist ein
digitaler Abo-Service für Zeitschriften
und Zeitungen so etwas wie es Spotify
für Printmedien es bietet mir eine
Unmenge meiner deutschsprachigen und
internationalen Lieblingstitel die
jederzeit nur einen Klick entfernt sind
ohne dass ich Zick Abos bei
verschiedenen Verlagen abschließen
müsste ganz genau redley ermöglicht es
mir mit nur einem Abo auf über 7000
Zeitschriften und Millionen Artikel
zuzugreifen und das beste man kann sein
Konto mit bis zu fünf anderen Menschen
teilen das macht ready zur perfekten
Lösung für die gesamte Familie der
Hammer gibt es das Ganze im ersten Monat
für 99 Cent danach beträgt der Preis
wieder 11,99 € pro Monat man kann das
Abo aber jederzeit kündigen also lass es
dir nicht entgehen so und jetzt fragst
du dich aber sicher welchen konnte dir
ready eigentlich bietet und ich habe
mich dies auch gefragt und war dann
komplett baff von renommierten
Qualitätszeitungen wie z.B den Neuen
Zürcher Zeitung einer der letzten
Bastion des deutschsprachigen Liberalen
Journalismus dem Guardian dem
independent der Welt und unglaublich
vielen anderen über unzählige
wissenschaftsratgeber Finanz und
hobby-magazine bis hin zu Comics das
Sortiment wird auch ständig erweitert
kürzlich ist zum Beispiel das komplette
Angebot des border Verlags inklusive
Fokus Focus Money und so weiter
hinzugekommen mich hat vor allem
beeindruckt das wirklich aus allen Ecken
des politischen Spektrums was dabei ist
ob links Mitte oder rechts so kann man
auch mal außerhalb seiner bubblestöbern
was er besonders wertvoll für die
Erweiterung des eigenen meinungshorizons
ist in diesem riesenreperator findest du
garantiert sowohl deine lieblingsmedien
als auch jede die du hast aber genau
diese Mischung macht doch am meisten
Spaß und bereitet unendliches
Lesevergnügen natürlich gibt es eine
offene Lesefunktion mit der man seine
Lieblingstitel auch überall unterwegs
gewesen kann auch wenn man gerade kein
Internet hat und überlegt mal digitales
Lesen von Magazin und Zeitungen und paar
Tonnen an CO2 und Müll ready hat
ausgerechnet dass es 16.600 Tonnen CO2
einsparnis etwa dem jährlichen Ausstoß
von 7000 PKW entspricht nicht schlecht
oder klicke jetzt gleich auf den Link in
der Videobeschreibung um den ersten
Monat für einen 99 Cent auszuprobieren
wie gesagt es ist unverbindlich und
jederzeit kündbar ich bin überzeugt dass
du dein neues Leseerlebnis genießen
wirst so und nun lasst uns wieder zur
Beantwortung unserer brennenden Fragen
kommen warum ist Deutschland für
Hochqualifizierte Ausländer so ohne
attraktiv wozu wird dies führen und was
unternimmt die Regierung dagegen
aufgepasst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Deutschland ist ein typisches toptenland
damit meine ich dass es ein praktisch
jedem Ranking für Wohlstand und
Entwicklung unter den ersten zehn
Ländern rangiert pro Kopf Bildungsniveau
Produktivitätsniveau Zugang zu
grundlegenden Dienstleistungen und so
weiter und so fort aber die hochmodernen
Fabriken die modernen Unterrichtsräume
und die mehr als beneidenswerten
jährlichen Investitionen die technischen
industrielle Entwicklung während
bedeutungslos wenn es keine Lehrer
Ingenieure Ärzte Arbeiter und Fachkräfte
gebe die diesen immensen
produktionsapparat in Gang setzen und
das Problem ist nun ein Bild sagt mehr
als 1000 Worte
gemäß offizielle unzahlen wird die
deutsche Bevölkerung ab 2023 schrumpfen
von einer Gesamtbevölkerung ausgehen von
der Zeit rund 83 Millionen Menschen wird
prognostiziert dass sie 80 Millionen
Marke im Jahr 2047 unterschritten wird
und im letzten Jahrzehnte jahrhundert da
die 70 Millionen Marke das ist zwar kein
so dramatischer Rückgang wie in Japan
oder Südkorea aber es dennoch
wirtschaftlich hochgradig relevant diese
Daten bedeuten im Grunde nicht nur
weniger Bevölkerung sondern auch eine
alternative bevölkerungsstruktion damit
viel weniger verfügbare Arbeitskräfte
[Musik]
logischerweise ist das alles eine Folge
der Veränderungen im gebärverhalten aber
es gibt noch etwas was die
wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen dies
Rückgangs verstärken kann die mangelnde
Bindung von Talenten ja Deutschland
bekommt eine Menge Zuwanderung das ist
sicher doch diese Geschichte hat ein
Problem jedes Mal wenn ein
hochqualifizierter deutscher
Arbeitnehmer in den Ruhestand geht ist
es nicht einfach ihn zu ersetzen denn
wir sehen werden gibt es in Deutschland
nicht nur kein Überschuss an Zuwanderung
sondern vor allem kein Überschuss an
qualifizierter Zuwanderung die Frage
lautet also wer könnte zum besten
Deutschland in dem wir je gelebt haben
denn nein sagen oder ihm gar den Rücken
kehren warum werden andere Ziele
bevorzugt das sind genau die Fragen auf
die wir Antworten finden müssen dazu
müssen wir aber zunächst einmal
verstehen wie wir eigentlich bis zu
diesem Punkt gekommen sind also schnallt
euch an es geht los
[Musik]
50 Jahre des demografischen
Niedersachsen
es handelt sich nicht nur um einen
Einzelfall die meisten Industrieländer
auch andere nicht zu entwickelte Länder
wie China und Russland erleben einen
beschleunigten Prozess der
demografischen Alterung und passt jetzt
gut auf denn dieser Prozess reduziert
nicht nur die verfügbaren Arbeitskräfte
sondern erhöht auch die öffentlichen
Ausgaben auf drastische Weise denkt mal
darüber nach es muss viel mehr für
Renten Gesundheitsversorgung und Pflege
ausgegeben werden und auf der anderen
Seite werden immer weniger Menschen da
sein die das dafür benötigte Geld
erarbeiten können tatsache ist dass
Deutschland das Problem erkannt hat und
rate mal was es hat schon sehr früh
damit begonnen sein Hausaufgaben zu
machen von nicht weniger als einem
halben Jahrhundert in den 1970er Jahren
gab es in Deutschland einen Wendepunkt
die einheimische indigene Bevölkerung
begann bereits zu schrumpfen das heißt
das Land trat in eine Phase ist
negativen Bevölkerungswachstums ein
wie ihr der folgenden Grafik entnehmen
könnt übersteigt seit den 70er Jahren
die Zahl der Sterbefälle jedes Jahr die
Zahl der Geburten um dies zu
kompensieren hat Deutschland damit
begonnen die Zuwanderung zu erhöhen wie
ihr seht ist die Zahl der Einwanderer
die jedes Jahr nach Deutschland kommen
in der Regel größer als der Verlust an
Einwohner darum konnte das Land sein
Bevölkerungswachstum über die Jahre
hinweg aufrecht erhalten
das Problem das Wohl und Wehe
Deutschlands hängt davon ab dass immer
wieder und immer mehr neue Einwanderer
ins Land kommen das Land hat den Vater
demografisch auch Taten Nachhaltigkeit
nicht nur was vor 50 Jahren verlassen
sondern weicht davon immer weiter ab und
man muss kein großer Ökonom oder
Soziologe sein um zu kapieren dass dies
nicht auf immer und ewig weitergehen
kann irgendwann geht es gehörig schief
und wenn ihr euch die Grafik genau
ansehen werdet ihr feststellen wie zu
Beginn des 21 Jahrhundert dass die
ersten Alarmzeichen aufleuchteten die
Zahl neue Einwanderer gegen rapide
zurück zu Beginn des 21 jahrhunderts
wuchs die Wirtschaft in fast ganz Europa
und zwar schneller als in Deutschland
Deutschland war nun bei weitem nicht die
einzige Blume in einem immer größer
werdenden Garten des Wohlstands und das
hatte natürlich folgen der Wettbewerb
mit anderen Nationen verlangsamte den
Zustrom neue Arbeitskräfte in die
deutschen Industrien tja und was haben
die Deutschen unternommen die Wahrheit
ist dass dieses Problem durchaus sehr
ernst genommen wurde die damalige
Regierung wusste wie wichtig es war
junge Talente anzuziehen und das
demografische Wachstum aufrecht zu
erhalten und zu verhindern dass die
Wirtschaft und das
Sozialversicherungssystem in eine Krise
geraten und ihre Ziele zu erreichen
förderten sie nicht nur aktiv die
Einwanderung sondern taten auch Dinge
wie diese hier erster januar 2005 das
erste deutsche Einwanderungsgesetz in
Kraft ab dem nächsten Jahr haben
Neuzuwanderer das Recht ein staatlich
finanzierten Deutschkursen teilzunehmen
und eine Einführung in das Rechtssystem
die Kultur und die Geschichte des Landes
zu erhalten die Regierung hat mehr als
200 Millionen Euro für dieses Programm
bereitgestellt
[Musik]
die Maßnahmen der damaligen
rot-grün-regierung haben gewirkt und die
nettozahl der Einwanderer die jedes Jahr
ins Land kam hat sich fast verdreifacht
von 73.000 im Jahr 2004 stieg die Zahl
auf 212.000 im Jahr 2008 und nicht nur
das im Jahr 2016 wurde eine der
historischen Höchstzahlen erreicht
432.000 nicht deutsche zogen ins Land
der Germanen das Schlimmste schien also
vorerst abgewendet scheinbar doch dann
kam erstmal ein anderer Faktor ins Spiel
als Mitglieder Europäischen Union steht
Deutschland im Rahmen der
arbeitnehmerfreiheitsmöglichkeit in
einem Wettbewerb mit anderen
Mitgliedstaaten und hatten die Deutschen
z.B noch in den 90er Jahren Angst davor
dass ihnen billige aber kompetente
Handwerker aus dem neuen östlichen
Mitgliedern die Jobs wegnehmen haben
sich diese Verhältnisse mittlerweile
gerade zu umgekehrt hatte Deutschland
damals zum Beispiel zeitweilig auch
Beschränkungen der
arbeitnehmerkreismöglichkeit bestanden
um sein Arbeitsmarkt vor Einwanderern zu
schützen wäre es nun froh wenn andere
Staaten in diese nicht wegnehmen würden
jedes der EU-Mitglieder ist zu einem
konkurrenzland für Arbeitskräfte
geworden mehr noch es handelt sich um
einen immer intensiver werden Wettbewerb
mit dem Deutschland anscheinend nicht
besonders gut umgehen kann also
aufpassen
[Musik]
danke aber nein danke
ab 2013 verlangte sich wieder der
Zustrom von Einwanderer nach Deutschland
und was noch schlimmer war laut OECD
berichten wo sie das Land besonders für
gut ausgebildete Fachkräfte immer
unattraktiver denn und das ist wichtig
nicht alle Menschen sind gleich aus
wirtschaftlicher Sicht ist es logisch
dass Qualifikationen zählen und aus
diesem Grund hat die folgende Warnung
ausgesprochen 4 februar 2013
Arbeitsmigration Deutschland ist offen
für Hochschulabsolventen aber
Zuwanderung ist für Mittel qualifizierte
Arbeitskräfte schwierig und warum ist
die hier so deutlich geworden nur vor
allem aus folgenden Grund achtet auf die
Daten deutschland ist eines der
osi-länder mit den niedrigsten
einwanderungs Barriere für
hochqualifizierte Arbeitskräfte die Zahl
der Zugewanderten Arbeitskräfte von
außerhalb der EU unter europäischen
Freihandelszone 11 da liegt jedoch bei
25000 pro Jahr was etwa 0,02 Prozent der
Bevölkerung entspricht die Quote der
qualifizierten Zuwanderer die Australien
Dänemark Kanada und das Vereinigte
Königreich erhalten ist fünf bis zehnmal
höher mit anderen Worten es war
angeblich relativ einfach nach
Deutschland einzuwandern aber trotzdem
bevorzugten und bevorzugen noch immer
Fachkräfte andere Ziele und ob es an der
Sprache den Standard oder den Lebensstil
liegt tatsache ist das Deutschland kein
beliebtes Ziel für Leute ist die was
können und das meine Lieben Zuschauer
ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
eine Umfrage des international Institute
in der Schweiz ergab dass deutsche
Arbeitgeber die Chancen der Rekrutierung
internationaler Talente eher schlecht
einschätzen können mit anderen Worten
der oised Bericht spiegelt nicht die
gesamte Realität wieder der volle Umfang
der Misere durfte noch viel größer und
tiefgreifender ausfallen nun ja es
scheint dass die Bürokratie schon seit
einem Jahrzehnt ein Problem ist und was
hat die deutsche Bundesregierung um die
im Vergleich zu den Anreizen in den
Nachbarländer veraltete deutsche
Gesetzgebung zur Anwerbung
qualifizierter Zuwanderer aus dem Jahr
2015 modernisieren nun viele Jahre lang
übte sich Angela Merkel darin
gebetsmühlenhaft zu wiederholen dass
Deutschland kein Einwanderungsland sei
kurz gesagt
opportunistin die sie nun mal ist
richtete sie sich nach der größten
potentiellen Wählergruppe die ist damals
abzufischen gab den latenten
nationalistischen und
traditionalistischen
realitätsverweigerern erst zwischen 2018
und 2020 hat der Bundestag mehrere
Gesetzesänderung vorgenommen die ist
Fachkräften von außerhalb der EU
einfacher machen in Deutschland
produktiv zu werden zum Beispiel wurde
es vereinwanderer einfacher ohne
bestehenden Arbeitsvertrag zu kommen
diese längst überfällige
politikwechselte natürlich nicht auf 61
sondern war er ein Nebenprodukte
Abfischung einer anderen Gruppe von
realitätsverweigerern nämlich den
komplexierten narzisstischen Verfechtern
einer bedingungslosen Willkommenskultur
für unqualifizierte Einwanderer dazu
aber später mehr den erstmal veränderte
Corona das Bild völlig die weltweiten
lockdowns und Reisebeschränkungen
brachten die Ankunft neue Einwanderer
zum Stillstand und zwar die Einwanderer
alle Art qualifizierte wie ungelernt hat
das hat die Probleme auf lange sich
natürlich noch schlimmer
seit 2013 beobachtet die Bundesagentur
für Arbeit selbst was die Behörden als
engpassberufe bezeichnen das sind
Bereiche des Arbeitsmarktes in denen
offene Stellen nicht mit verfügbaren
Arbeitskräften besetzt werden können im
Jahr 2020 hat sich diese Situation
abgekühlt aber seither ist der Trend
wieder da immer mehr Bereiche der
deutschen Wirtschaft sind nicht in der
Lage an die von Ihnen benötigten
Fachkräfte zu kommen es wird sogar
erwartet dass dieser Indikator im Jahr
2023 einen neuen Rekordwert erreichen
wird
der wirtschaftliche Aufschwung im Zuge
der Öffnung nach den lockdowns in
Verbindung mit der
zunehmendemografischen Alterung bringt
den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt in einen
zunehmend kritischen Kontext während die
Nachfrage nach Arbeitskräften weiter
steigt ist die Zahl der Einwanderer die
jedes Jahr kommen zurückgegangen ganz zu
schweigen von der Zahl qualifizierter
Zuwanderer um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben wovon wir sprechen
nachschätzungen des Instituts der
deutschen Wirtschaft in Köln gab es
Mitte 2022 bereits 1,5 offene Stellen in
diesem Land eine Zahl die den nächsten
Jahren voraussichtlich noch stark
ansteigen wird die Situation Situation
hat ein solches Ausmaß erreicht das
einige Branchen ihre Dienstleistungen
nur noch auf einer reduzierten Basis
anbieten können und genau das ist es was
Nachrichten wie diese erklärt 25 Juni
2022 Deutschland wird ausländische
Zeitarbeitskräfte einsetzen um den
Personalmangel an deutschen Flughäfen zu
lindern Fotos von Reisenden die in
langen Schlangen an den
Sicherheitskontrollen des Düsseldorfer
Flughafen standen sagten Anfang der
Woche das Ausmaß des Mannes neuer
Höchststand 2022 diesen Branchen fehlen
die meisten Arbeitskräfte rechnerisch
konnten in diesen Bereichen sechs von
zehn offenen Stellen nicht besetzt
werden Gesundheit und Soziales Lehrer
und Erziehung bauvermessung und
Gebäudetechnik überdurchschnittlich hoch
war der Fachkräftemangel laut
Untersuchung darüber hinaus in Folgen
Naturwissenschaften Geographie
Informatik Expertinnen und Experten mit
Hochschulabschluss waren in diesem
Branchen besonders gesucht Informatik
Elektrotechnik Bauplanung und
Überwachung hier fehlten der Studie
zufolge rechnerisch für 9 von 10 offenen
Stellen entsprechend qualifizierte
Arbeitslose mit anderen Worten die
deutsche Wirtschaft braucht dringend
Arbeitskräfte aller Art
Schätzungen des Deutschen Instituts für
Arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung werden
jährlich mindestens 400.000
qualifizierte neu ankündigen benötigt um
die Zahl der Arbeitskräfte stabil zu
halten
und das ist ein gewaltiges Problem denn
verfügbare Fachkräfte zählen in diesem
Land sowieso schon fast als eine
gefährdete Spezies laut einer Umfrage
vom dezember 2022 leiden sieben von zehn
Unternehmen an einem Mangel an
Fachkräften der ihr Wachstum oder gar
ihr Kerngeschäft einschränkt und als
wäre das noch nicht schlimm genug steht
Deutschland jetzt vor einem weiteren
Problem es ist nicht nur so dass zu
wenige Fachkräfte kommen sondern dass
viele von ihnen das Land mittlerweile
verlassen ja ganz genau das Land der
Dichte und Denker leidet unter einem
Rain und das meine Lieben Zuschauer ist
ein Faktor der jene beeindruckende
Industrie ernsthaft gefährdet die den
größten Wirtschaftsmotor Europas
antreibt wenn diese so richtig in
Stottern gerät dann drohen alle
finanzierungsmechanismen die die EU
zusammenhalten zusammenzubrechen was die
Wirtschaft wiederum noch tiefer in den
Abgrund ziehen würde eine gesamt
europäische abwehrspirale wäre die Folge
gegen die japanische wie ein
Kindergeburtstag aussehen würde aber
lasst uns zu der Frage zurückkehren die
wir am Anfang gestellt haben wie um
alles in der Welt ist es möglich dass es
fast keine Fachkräfte gibt die in einem
der am weitesten entwickelten Länder der
Welt leben und arbeiten wollen worin
liegt das Problem könnte man es lösen um
den Niedergang Deutschland und Europas
doch noch irgendwie aufzuhalten hört
jetzt gut zu
die drei Säulen der talentschmelze
wenn wir versuchen die ganze Sache auf
den Punkt zu bringen könnten wir sagen
dass Deutschland vor drei riesigen
Probleme steht jedes von ihnen hängt mit
den anderen zusammen 1 man kann nicht
erwarten dass der Bestand an
Humankapital in Europa ewig hält
[Musik]
und warum sage ich das nun nach
offiziellen Angaben hat Serbien in den
letzten drei Jahrzehnten neun Prozent
seine Einwohner verloren noch Mazedonien
10%
24% und Albanien sage und schreibe
siebenunddreißig Prozent ehrlich jetzt
könnte man auch über Polen und die
baltischen Republiken sagen all diese
Länder die traditionell in der Lage sind
ihre jungen Menschen gut auszubilden
unsere Tüchtigkeit zu erziehen haben
einen großen Teil ihrer best
ausgebildeten und qualifiziertesten
jungen Menschen verloren und vergessen
wir nicht dass Europa ein starker
Kontinent ist so dass der Pool an
frischen qualifizierten Fachkräften die
deutsche Unternehmen aus dem
europäischen Ausland anziehen können
begrenzt ist im Grunde genommen ist das
Resort und Fachkräften auf dem ganzen
Kontinent nicht mehr groß genug
[Musik]
in diesem Sinne glauben viele Experten
dass der aufnahmeeffekte Erweiterungen
bereits aufgehört hat zu wirken einzige
Ausnahme war bis zuletzt die Ukraine
aber auch dieses Land hat bereits eine
große Abwanderung von Fachkräften
insbesondere von jungen Menschen erlebt
aus diesem Grund weisen viele Analysten
darauf hin dass die Suche nach Talenten
über die kontinentalen Grenzen
hinausgehen muss und wisst ihr was genau
das hat dazu geführt das mit der Reform
des fachkräftezuwanderungsgesetzes 2020
mehr Erleichterung für qualifizierte
Zuwanderer aus Drittstaaten eingeführt
worden so wurden z.B keine
Hochschulabschlüsse in der verlangsamt
auch eine Berufsausbildung als
Qualifikationsnachweis akzeptiert
Halleluja eine Forderung die deutsche
Arbeitgeber schon seit einiger Zeit
stellen und warum nun wird einfach einen
Blick auf diese Kraft
das war natürlich nicht die einzige
Maßnahme es wurden auch einige
administrative Formalitäten reduziert
das Problem an der ganzen Geschichte der
größte Stolperstein wurde nicht
beseitigt worum es dabei geht
nun das bürokratische deutsche
einwanderungssystem ist extrem komplex
mindestens 7 Ministerien sind an den
Prozess beteiligt ohne die Behörden der
zweiten Ebene und die Kommunen zu
berücksichtigen um nur ein Beispiel zu
nennen die Zulassung einer
qualifizierten Fachkraft benötigen Segen
folgender staatlicher Stellen das
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz das Ministerium für Arbeit
und soziale Angelegenheiten das
Ministerium für Bildung und Forschung
des Ministerium für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft das Ministerium für
Gesundheit des Ministerium für Inneres
und Kommunales und das Ministerium für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung ihr seht also alles total
unbürokratisch und unkompliziert in gut
old Germany
[Musik]
was für ein mega Anreiz für deutsche
Unternehmen im Jahr 2022 rekrutierten
nur 17 Prozent der von der Bertelsmann
Stiftung befragten Unternehmen
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland und während
große Unternehmen Beratungsfirmen und
Anwaltskanzleien beauftragen können um
den Prozess zu beschleunigen stehen
kleine und mittlere Firmen vor einem
fast unüberwindbaren Hindernis das heißt
die Verlängerung der Förderfähigkeit bis
2020 war ein gewisser Weise einen
Schritt in die richtige Richtung und
Fachkräfte von außerhalb der EU
anzuziehen aber sie hat die Bürokratie
nicht auf eine solche Herausforderung
vorbereitet die Mobilität innerhalb des
gemeinsamen europäischen Blocks ist viel
einfacher aber wenn man anfängt
Fachkräfte aus anderen Region zu
integrieren vervielfachen sich die
bürokratischen Anforderungen und Hürden
es ist unendlich viel schwieriger und
teurer einen thailändischen oder wenn es
zulantischen Arbeitnehmer einzustellen
als einen polnischen aber von denen gibt
es eben nicht mehr so viele die nach
Deutschland wollen das ist also das
zweite Problem und schließlich hat der
dritte große Stolperstein mit einem viel
komplexeren Faktor zu tun nämlich mit
dem kulturellen Faktor allein schon
wegen der Sprache
im August 2022 hat sich die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit mit diesem
Thema befasst und wisst ihr was sie
herausgefunden hat dass die meisten
Arbeitnehmer die ohne Deutschkenntnisse
nach Deutschland kommen sich nicht
einmal die Mühe machen die Landessprache
zu lernen warum entweder weil sie ist
vorziehen in der Bubble ihrer
Parallelgesellschaften zu leben oder
aber meist sowieso schon daran denken
wieder zu gehen
so verhindern deutsche Behörden das
dringend benötigte Arbeitsmigranten
kommen auch das Verhalten so manche
Auslandsvertretungen und
Ausländerbehörden stößt erwerbsmigranten
vor den Kopf so sehr dass mehrere
Anwälte für migrationsrecht nun
deutliche Kritik üben von unwürdigen
Verfahren ist die Rede fehlenden
Feingefühl und Behörden die Bewerber um
einen Aufenthaltstitel über Monate
ghosten in einigen Fällen wird hier auch
die Grenze des rechtlich Zulässigen
deutlich überschritten die Folge ist ein
wirtschaftlicher Verlust für alle
Beteiligten der Mangel einfach und
Arbeitskräften Bremse in vielen
Unternehmen Wachstum und Innovation
diese Kafka Essen Verhältnisse können
sich Deutschland nicht mehr leisten
Behörden Willkür und Chaos sprachliche
Integrationsprobleme Probleme bei der
Erlangung eines dauerhaften Aufenthalts
Wohnkosten Lebenshaltungskosten und
Steuern Probleme bei der Familie
Zusammenführung im Land und der Konflikt
mit der lokalen Kultur sind die
häufigsten Argumente von Fachkräften die
sich entscheiden Deutschland wieder zu
verlassen der Grad an Identifikation mit
dem Einwanderungsland ist mäserabel
darüber haben wir auch visual economics
bereits berichtet erschwerend kommt
hinzu dass die einwanderungsgesetzgebung
mit einer neuen Art von Wert kollidiert
die praktisch ignoriert wird
Freiberufler und Selbstständigen diese
stellen dabei gerade in der heutigen
Wirtschaftswelt einen unglaublich
wichtigen Faktor für Flexibilität
Innovation und damit die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Wirtschaft da
diese drei Probleme scheint zu erklären
warum Deutschland als Land nicht so
attraktiv ist wie es sein sollte
schließlich stellt auch eine Studie
durch Akademie der technikwissenschaften
fest dass Deutschland seine
Attraktivität als Einwanderungsland
erhöhen muss um zukünftige Fachkräfte
Engpässe zu bewältigen die inländischen
Potenziale sein und weitestgehend
ausgeschöpft die Herausforderungen
umfassen Bürokratie lange Prozesse
mangelnde Digitalisierung und
Bildungsdefizite eine ganz neue Art und
Qualität der Willkommenskultur
insbesondere von Seiten der Behörden
wird als entscheidende achtet um die
Konkurrenzfähigkeit des
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschlands zu
erhalten das Problem ist all das haben
wir bereits 2015 zu Zeiten der großen
migrationskrise gehört damals
versprachen sowohl Politiker als auch
Wirtschaftsführer dass der massive Zuzug
aus dem Ausland die Bedürfnisse
Industrie Decken und verwirtschaftliche
Blüte sorgen werden werde acht Jahre
später ist jedoch weitestgehend
Ernüchterung eingetreten die Integration
der Migranten in den Arbeitsmarkt hängt
sowohl den damaligen Erwartungen als
auch den Erfordernissen deutlich
hinterher und dass die Deutschen
Defizite des systemisch und
gesellschaftlich angelegt sind zeigte
sich erst kürzlich bei der Integration
der ukrainischen Kriegsflüchtlinge
nämlich ausgerechnet im Vergleich mit
den Nachbarländern die nach 2015 von den
Deutschen noch als einwanderungs- und
integrationsmuffel kritisiert wurde z.B
Polen Estland oder Tschechien wenn die
so oft kam für die Deutschen nach ihrem
Hochmut der tiefe Fall
während in den anderen Aufnahmeländern
mindestens ein Drittel in Polen sogar
zwei Drittel der ukrainischen Suchenden
Arbeit gefunden haben sind es in
Deutschland nur ernüchternde 12 Prozent
das kann kein Zufall sein die niedrige
Beschäftigungsquote ukrainischer
Flüchtlinge in Deutschland im Vergleich
zu anderen Ländern ist auf
unterschiedliche integrationsstrategien
zurückzuführen während in einigen
Ländern die Sozialleistung
verflüchtlinge eingeschränkt werden und
sie daher gezwungen sind auch unter
schwierigen Bedingungen zu arbeiten
erhalten Flüchtlinge in Deutschland
Bürgergeld darüber hinaus gibt es
Unterschiede in der allgemeinen
Atmosphäre und der Art und Weise wie die
Integration gefördert wird in Estland
werden Unternehmen ermutigt Ukraine
während der Arbeit beim Erlernen der
Sprache zu unterstützen dies stützt sich
auf die Erkenntnis das Sprachen am
besten durch tägliche Interaktion in der
Praxis erlernt werden es ermöglicht
darüber hinaus auch eine schnellere
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt im
Gegensatz dazu setzt Deutschland auf
staatliche Maßnahmen bevor Flüchtlinge
überhaupt in den Arbeitsmarkt integriert
werden Ukraine in Deutschland sind in
der Regel verpflichtet ein Sprach- und
orientierungskursen teilzunehmen die oft
sechs bis neun Monate dauern die
bundesre großen Wert darauf dass
Migranten einen Integrationskurs
besuchen da durchkenntnisse als
entscheidend für die Integration in
Arbeitsmarkt und die Gesellschaft
angesehen werden während einige Länder
also einen eher pragmatischer Ansatz
verfolgen und die schnelle Eingliederung
in den Arbeitsmarkt realisieren liegt
Deutschland Wert auf eine scheinbar
gründliche Integration die das Erlernen
der Sprache und die gesellschaftliche
Eingliederung in den Vordergrund stellt
dies führt aber letzten Endes nur zu
längeren Zeiträumen bis zur
Arbeitsaufnahme und riskiert damit die
Integrationsfähigkeit und die Ergebnisse
zeigen nun dass die Deutschen mit ihrer
verkauft bürokratisierten Strategie mal
wieder daneben liegen tja auf
Deutschland als Einwanderungsland
scheint förmlich ein Flug zu liegen es
scheint nie die richtige Balance zu
finden und verfängt sich oft in eher
extrem Strategien mit entsprechend
extremen folgen die Frage ist also gibt
es noch einen Ausweg für Deutschland was
tun die deutschen Politiker keine Angst
denn das nehmen wir jetzt genau unter
die Lupe
[Musik]
die Deutschland wieder schick werden
will
[Musik]
nach Schätzungen des
Bundesarbeitsministeriums werden bis zum
Jahr 2026 mehr als 200.000 Stellen
unbesetzt bleiben falls sich die
geschilderte Situation nicht schnell und
drastisch ändert eine Situation die sich
sehr negativ auf Unternehmen
Produktivität und das
Wirtschaftswachstum des Landes auswirken
könnte deshalb stand das Thema zunächst
im Oktober 2022 ganz oben auf der
öffentlichen Agenda 22 Oktober 2022 wie
Deutschland qualifizierte Ausländer
anziehen will zu den Reformen gehören
die Einführung einer sogenannten
chancenkarte die nach einem Punktesystem
zur Arbeitssuche in Deutschland
berechtigt das unter anderem auch
Sprachkenntnissen Berufserfahrung und
Verbindungen zu Deutschland basiert der
ampelberg kreiste und gebar schließlich
Ende März 2023 einen Entwurf zum
angeblich modernsten Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz der Welt zumindest
nach Aussage von Olaf Scholz 29 März
2023 Ausländer mit ausreichenden
Berufserfahrungen Ausbildung in ihrem
Heimatland dürfen in Deutschland
arbeiten auch wenn diese beruflichen
Qual Informationen Deutschland nicht
anerkannt werden außerdem dürfen sie bis
zu 20 Stunden pro Woche arbeiten während
sie eine langfristige Beschäftigung
suchen schließlich wird das Personen mit
akademischen Abschlüssen oder
berufszeugnissen möglich sein bis zu
einem Jahr in Deutschland zu bleiben
wären sie eine Beschäftigung suchen mehr
als zwei Monate später im Juni 2023 war
dieses Gesetz immer noch nicht
verabschiedet denn die ampelkoalitionäre
mussten es grundsätzlich nachjustieren
das neue Gesetze Erleichterung der
fachkräfteeinwanderung sieht nun unter
anderem ein Punktesystem nach
kanadischen Vorbild und die erleichterte
Anerkennung ausländischer
Berufsabschlüsse vor Punkte können zum
Beispiel Sprachkenntnisse oder Erfahrung
in einem mangelberuf gesammelt werden
Personen die die Kriterien erfüllen
dürfen bis zu 2 Jahre in Deutschland
arbeiten ein Spurwechsel von
Asylverfahren zu arbeiten Migration wird
ermöglicht aber nur rückwirkend und
keine Fehlanreize für ihre reguläre
Migration zu schaffen das Gesetz Ziel
darauf ab qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte
Ausländer außerhalb der EU anzuziehen
und Menschen ohne formale Qualifikation
leichter in den Arbeitsalltag
eingliedern oder ausbilden zu können
insgesamt erhofft man sich dadurch
60.000 neue Arbeitskräfte pro Jahr
zukünftig soll die Steuer der
Zuwanderung im Fokus stehen statt ihrer
Begrenzung die soll eine
Willkommenskultur für ausländische
Arbeitskräfte Förderung gleichzeitig die
irregulären Migration unqualifizierter
und nicht arbeitswilliger reduzieren die
neuen Gesetze Zielen auch darauf ab
Lohndumping zu verhindern und die
Vermischung von humanitäre Aufnahme und
Arbeitsmigration zu vermeiden parallel
soll eine Ausbildungsplatzgarantie für
Jugendliche eingeführt werden trotz
Bedenken in Bezug auf pulleffekte ist
Asylsystem und die Notwendigkeit einer
klaren Trennung zwischen Asylverfahren
und Arbeitsmigration betont die
Regierungsparteien dass sie den
deutschen Arbeitsmarkt für
internationale Fachkräfte öffnen und
gleichzeitig die Menschen
berücksichtigen wollen die bereits in
Deutschland leben die Preisfrage lautet
daher wird diese neue Reform
funktioniert unser vorläufiges Fazit
[Musik]
das neue Zuwanderungsgesetz der
ampelregierung ist ein erster guter
Ansatz wird aber bei weitem nicht in der
Lage sein die vielen sich durch
jahrzehntelange Vernachlässigung
angestauten Probleme Deutschlands zu
lösen das Punktesystem und die
erleichterte Anerkennung ausländische
Berufsabschlüsse und Erfahrung während
sich sicher positiv auf die
Attraktivität Deutschlands für
tüchtlinge und qualifizierte
Arbeitsmigranten auswerten sie erreichen
jedoch bei weitem nicht aus es gibt
bereits eine sehr hohe Zahl von
Bürgergeld also Sozialhilfeempfängern
die ohne eine strikte Begrenzung der
staatlichen und unversorgung nie in den
Arbeitsmarkt finden werden hinzu kommen
interne systemische Probleme wie
Ineffizienz und Bearbeitung Stopper
auseinanderbehörden und unzureichende
Maßnahmen um das inländische
Arbeitskräftepotenzial zu nutzen alle
bisherigen Bemühungen ausländische
Fachkräfte anzuziehen haben nicht die
gewünschten Ergebnisse erzielt
währenddessen ist die Attraktivität
Deutschlands für ausländische Talente in
den letzten Jahren unaufhaltsam gesunken
und wird es weiterhin tun beim Vergleich
zu anderen Einwanderung sondern sowohl
erhebliche staatliche als auch
gesellschaftlich strukturelle
Belastungen bestehen bleiben die
Regierung setzt auf Ausbildungs-
weiterhin werden in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten wesentlich mehr
qualifizierte Leistungsträger in den
Ruhestand gehen als nachwachsen es wird
erwartet dass Deutschland in den
kommenden Jahren weitere Beschäftigte
aufgrund der Überalterung verlieren wird
was unweigerlich zu einer weiteren
Verschlechterung der Winden
Standortfaktoren führt der einzige Weg
um aus dieser sich selbst verstärkenden
Abwärtsspirale zu kommen werden wirklich
umfassende gesellschaftliche Reformen
und natürlich echte mutige politische
Lösungen für Probleme wie hohe Mieten
teure Energiepreise gesellschaftliche
und politische Radikalisierung
Ausgrenzung und natürlich irgendwie
Verfestigung von Parallelgesellschaften
in den bildungsferner Verklärung und
emanzipationsfeindlichkeit über
Generation hinweg zementiert werden dass
die aktuellen Regierungsparteien hierfür
irgendwelche Rezepte parat hätten ist
nicht im entferntesten abzusehen denn
dazu müssten sie mit Tabus brechen diese
in weiten Teil zu ihren eigenen Idealen
oder gar zum Teil ihrer Identität
erkoren haben trotzdem ähnliche Probleme
gab und gibt es z.B auch in Schweden und
Dänemark und dort sind immerhin erste
Anzeichen echter Reformierung zu
erkennen vielleicht werden die Deutschen
ja irgendwann in der Lage sein sich
diese
Vorbild zu nehmen aber darüber werden
wir dann in weiteren Videos sprechen
vergisst also bitte nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen um keines davon zu verpassen
und was meint ihr eigentlich wie könnte
Deutschland eurer Meinung nach den Zuzug
neuer Talente fördern wird es irgendwann
wieder ein attraktives Einwanderungsland
für qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte werden
gibt es eure Meinung nach Politiker die
den Willen und den Mut zu echten
Reformen hätten wie immer sind wir auf
eure ressour zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und die
vielleicht auch besser dabei gelernt
habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like
und fallen um es mit ihnen auch
ausgiebig zu diskutieren natürlich
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns halt dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr wie immer in
der Beschreibung unter dem Video mach's
gut und bis bald
[Musik]